numpy is fast but how can we make it
even faster stay tuned to find out
welcome to AI adventures where we
explore the art science and tools of
machine learning my name is Yu Feng Guo
and on this episode we're going to look
at a new library from Google research
called Jack's and see how it can speed
up machine learning Jack's can
automatically differentiate native
Python and numpy functions it can
differentiate through loops branches
recursion and closures and it can take
derivatives of derivatives of
derivatives
it supports reverse mode differentiation
also known as back propagation using the
grad function as well as forward mode
differentiation and the two can be
composed arbitrarily in any order you
want it can seem kind of like every
other library these days supports auto
differentiation so what else can Jax do
well it's also able to speed up your
code sometimes really significantly by
using a special compiler under the hood
accelerated linear algebra or excel a is
a domain-specific compiler for linear
algebra it can perform optimizations
like fusing operations together so
intermediate results don't need to be
written out to memory instead of this
time consuming process this data it gets
streamed right into the next operation
and this enables faster and more
efficient processing Jack's uses excel a
to compile and run your numpy programs
on GPUs and Tipu's compilation happens
transparently with numpy library calls
getting sped up but Jax takes it a step
further than xla alone as it lets you
just in time compile your very own
Python functions into excel a optimized
kernels using a single function API
called JIT compilation and automatic
differentiation can be composed
arbitrarily so you
can express sophisticated algorithms and
get maximal performance all without
leaving Python what else is there other
than JIT there's also P map applying P
map means that the function you write
gets compiled by Excel a just like JIT
and replicated and then executed in
parallel across devices that's what the
P in P map stands for this means you can
do compilations on multiple GPUs or TPU
cores all at once using P map and then
differentiate through them all Jax boils
down to an extensible system for
composable function transformations the
main ones today are grad legit P map and
also V map V map is used for automatic
vectorization allowing you to turn a
function that can handle only one data
point into a function that can handle a
batch of these data points of any size
with just a single wrapper function
let's take a look at how this all comes
together using a familiar example
training a deep neural network on the M
nest data set this notebook starts out
by creating two utility functions to
make a neural network with just randomly
initialized parameters I've printed out
the dimensions of each layer for
convenience we can see here that it
takes a 784 unit wide input and passes
through two hidden layers whose size is
512 each and the outputs are the usual
10 classes since we're predicting what
digit is supposed to be in that image
next we have a function that takes care
of running an image through our predict
function our predict function only
handles one image at a time and we can
confirm this by passing in a single
random image of the correct dimensions
which gives us a vector of size 10
representing the 10 logit values coming
out of the final layer of the network
but when we try a whole batch of images
say of length 10 also it fails
since the array dimension is no longer
line up but we're in luck because
wrapping our predict function in a V map
will allow us to take advantage of
matrix multiplication and run all 10
images through the model in a single
pass rather than doing them one by one
the resultant function can handle a
batch of
cherry sighs and we don't have to modify
our function one bit notice that the
output is now ten by ten representing
the ten logic values coming out of the
final layer for each of the ten examples
in that batch now let's see how we can
use the grad and JIT functions to build
out the remainder of our model as well
as our training code we'll add in a
function to one hotend code our data and
a couple more functions to calculate
accuracy and loss finally we'll put
together our update function which will
take the result of the loss function and
run Grad on it which will take care of
the back propagation for us and return
the updated parameters of the model now
we're almost ready to run our model we
just need to add in some code using
tensorflow datasets to bring in our M
this dataset
Jax purposely does not include dataset
loading functionality as it's focused on
program transformations and accelerator
backed numpy so now we're ready to train
our model our training loop is set for
10 epochs and we have a timer added in
as well because we want to see how it
performs so let's run this and we can
see that across 10 a box we end up
spending about 22 seconds per epoch now
you might be thinking wait wait didn't
you think mention something about using
the JIT function did we ever add that
good catch let's add in the at JIT
decorator at the top of our update
function and we'll rename it JIT update
now we'll have a before-and-after
comparison let's reinitialize our
parameters using the same init network
params function we used earlier and then
run our new training loop and we'll see
how the timing works out okay so this is
looking like it's taking way less time
only eight seconds per epoch and all we
had to do was add four characters to the
top of the update loop now that's legit
before I close this out I want to remind
viewers that as of this recording Jax is
still just a research project and not an
official Google product so it's likely
you may encounter bugs and sharp edges
the team has even made a list of gotchas
and a gotchas notebook to help you out
since this list will be constantly
evolving be sure to see what the state
of things are if you
on using JIT for your project thanks for
watching this episode of cloudy
adventures and if you enjoyed it click
that like button and be sure to
subscribe to get all the latest updates
right when they come out for now head on
over to github and try out Jack's send
over some bug reports and let the team
know what you think